hello or glad you've joined us through
this live webinar understanding the
analytical techniques required to
characterize cannabis and hemp samples
I'm Julia O'Rourke elaborate and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab route the leading scientific a
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by PerkinElmer
PerkinElmer is a global leader focused
on improving the health and safety of
people and their environment with
analytical instrumentation illumination
and detection technologies and leading
laboratory services they focus on
improving the integrity and safety of
the world we live in
additionally PerkinElmer provides a
partner for your cannabis analytical
needs they know analyzing cannabis can
be challenging from setting up a
laboratory developing methods to ensure
maximum throughput samples generating
client reports to preserving data
integrity more importantly as state and
country rules and regulations evolve
cannabis labs need instrumentation and
support that can meet new and stricter
demands difficult matrices like these
require the highest sensitivity and
greatest performance than ever before to
learn more please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers n tation
just click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credit
I now present today's speaker toby
asheville PhD the senior business
manager for cannabis and hemp markets at
PerkinElmer dr. astril has a PhD in
chemistry and has spent the last ten
years working in science technology and
business roles for leading technology
companies for the last seven years he
has worked for PerkinElmer based in
locations across the west coast of
Canada and the US
dr. Asheville is now focused on driving
PerkinElmer global cannabis and health
initiatives including but not limited to
new product development market and
industry research collaboration
agreements with customers application
content development and field marketing
initiatives
dr. Asheville will now begin his
presentation thank you it's a pleasure
to be here today thank you to lab roots
to give me this opportunity it's an
exciting time to be talking about
cannabis and hemp science I'm starting
on slide 1 I'd like to just introduce
myself again I'm based in Canada but
cover the globe and today we'll be
speaking about cannabis and hemp science
and how PerkinElmer can support your
laboratory needs
you
/ Konami yet we are a US company with
over 11,000 employees around the globe
we're 87 years old and we have a
significant amount of activity in
cannabis and hemp under our food
division where we look at the human
environmental science around these
applications
starting from the very beginning and
this predates me but approximately 2700
years ago cannabis was first seen or
identified in Asia since then through
various channels it circulated the globe
and now in a number of countries it is
in a legal capacity
you
it's not always been used for
recreational and medicinal uses cannabis
and hemp have been used for a number of
different products and applications in
the past with generations relying on the
fiber and food for their daily lives
more recently we've seen an increased
usage of the medicinal component of the
material which we'll be focusing in
today but just to provide some clarity
understanding on cannabis and hemp
really they come from the same species
of plant and depending on the chemistry
they can be classified as cannabis and
hemp this is a ongoing discussion but
federally the FDA classifies hemp is
having point three percent or less THC
in the plant what you're looking at here
is an example of cannabis on the left
and hemp on the right they look very
similar but can have different
chemistry's and if they are a hemp
chemistry it can be transported across
state lines in the US whereas cannabis
ten dots
and because of this federal
Galaxy there's a number of different
environments that people are working
with cannabis and those are usually at a
state level as each state that has a
recreational or medicinal market has
identified the testing and regulatory
framework necessary but we do realize
that this is a Schedule one substance so
has to be treated accordingly for any
shipping or international masses
but regardless of being Schedule one we
are now seeing a huge growth in the
medicinal and recreational cannabis
markets in the US
this slide shows us that over 30 states
now have a medical program
for cannabis nine have a recreational
program and 16 have a CBD or hemp
program and only four states have no
activity
this leads to a lot of science being
done in laboratories across the country
and a huge amount of new scientists and
technicians and engineers entering the
cannabis and hemp science space
also to note just to the north Canada
when recreationally legal last month on
October 17th this was a huge milestone
for Canada that is as it is the largest
country to have recreational cannabis
what this allows in Canada is importing
and exporting of cannabis products so we
are seeing international markets emerge
with South America Australia Europe the
UK etc so a lot of activity has happened
in the last two or three years in Canada
and continues to grow I want reference I
like to speak to is how quickly this
industry is growing as a whole
does it remember the VHS tape every
household in America and and if not the
globe quickly adopted VHS as the most
preferred media for watching movies what
we can do is compare the growth of VHS
acceptance to the growth of the cannabis
and hemp market we see that on this
slide here and we see that the green
star is the trajectory for the cannabis
industry and we see it growing much
faster than the VHS so this supports
that a lot of science and activity
that's happening now is only going to be
happening more in the near future so
it's exciting time to be involved in
this industry
but bringing it back to the chemistry
cannabis and hemp are very complex
matrix matrices and within the plant
within the flower within the leaves and
the stored there are a number of
different chemistry groups that some I
get
attention and some not so much briefly a
lot of people are focused on the
cannabinoid those are the medicinal
components that often the plant is
valued by and we also see a lot of
people characterizing the terpenes of
that same plant these are the volatiles
that we'll go into in more detail later
but we also see there's a number of
other chemistry's and some of these are
very important as well depending on the
product of the cannabis at the end of
the processing step
and those products can be very different
traditionally or historically most
people associate a candidate flower as
the the final product from a cannabis
plant for what we're seeing today for
various reasons particularly in the
recreational market is a huge diversity
in the sample type what we're looking at
here is some common categories for
cannabis and hemp products extracts our
products from using a solvent to remove
the cannabinoids and terpenoids all
vain' scan B butane ethanol co2 even
water at times but the extracts often
highly concentrated and very homogeneous
so they can be used and incorporated
into various products below we see an
example of edibles beverages and even
even novelty items with THC infused
toothpicks as a chemist this can be
quite challenging to handle in the lab
and to be quite challenging to get
quantitative data from these very
diverse starting points but it's an
exciting time to explore
but what we do see across all of the
cannabis and hemp markets in the
laboratory environment is that there is
very little standard methodology and
this does present a significant problem
it can lead to inaccurate results false
positives or just general poor practices
in the lab
there's also multiple techniques
suggested with 30-plus methods
circulating about labs struggle to find
the right one or two and also as a
biological sample the variance in the
sample itself is significant the
depending on where the sample is
selected from the plant from the top
middle or bottom you'll see a variation
in the cannabinoid concentration you'll
also see final products having
variability depending on how they were
mixed or made
all present a unique opportunity for
PerkinElmer and the cannabis and hemp
support team because ultimately we're
concerned about the human environmental
health in this market so we can address
this with a number of resources to help
the industry standardize
so I'd like to start is a quick snapshot
of the chemistry involved in the
California market chosen California
because it has a fairly comprehensive
and well thought-out list of chemistry's
that people have to test for to be
compliant in their market every state
decide upon this list and some states
have similar some states have more some
have less but California is a good
example because it includes the
cannabinoids on the top-left the
terpenes and the residual solvents
heavy metals and then finally on the
right the pesticides and the micro
toxins what I'd like today is to walk
you through each of these methods and
assays to speak a little bit more about
the chemistry and some of the challenges
that can present themselves
and with an overall objective of being
able to support with an SOP that's
standard operating procedure and the
resources from Perkin our to be to allow
the lab to be successful
this is a quick snapshot of the
instrumentation that most cannabis labs
need to comply to the California list as
you'll notice it's a multiple instrument
portfolio unfortunately not one
instrument is able to test all the
chemistry's in California and this is
similar for the other markets where
testing is required and also other
countries like Canada but very briefly
you'll hear the acronyms icp-ms
inductively coupled plasma mass
spectrometry which is used for heavy
metals you're here GCMs gas
chromatography mass spectrometry
headspace analysis used for the residual
solvents terpenes and flavonoids
you're here HPLC or high pressure liquid
chromatography for testing the
cannabinoid or hemp potency and lastly
you'll hear LC ms/ms or liquid
chromatography mass spec spec or LCM s
triple quad and this technique is used
for pesticides and micro toxins so
starting with one of the most important
which is the cannabinoid concentration
of the sample or the cannabis or hemp
concentration we use HPLC
HPLC is the preferred technique because
you're able to capture both the acidic
component of THC a and THC in the same
test
chromatography experiment the heat of
the GC D carboxylates the THC a so you
only see THC in the final results
because we want to confirm and
quantitate everything in the plant from
the start
you
we use HPLC here we're looking at 16
cannabinoids all of these can be
quantitated and analyzed in a sample
there is an opportunity to test for more
cannabinoids but most states regulate 12
to 16
and what we can see here is the
chromatography of some real-life
cannabis samples taken out of the Oregon
and California market what you'll see is
that the chemistry's do differ a little
bit and you'll see that the sample types
are very different as well we have a
chocolate bar a gummy a hard candy and
even a lip balm what this presents of
some unique preparation differences and
challenges potentially to the lab so
where we try to help is by providing a
fairly precise well thought-out
extraction and preparatory
method for each of these different types
of sample yes there are a number of
different samples out there but we find
most fall into the various category
categories we see here
moving from the HPLC to LC ms/ms this is
a technique that has gained a lot of
attention lately because it's a
technique used to study or characterize
pesticides so our goal was to develop a
sensitive method for both cannabis and
hemp pesticides for all geographies
and all regulatory lists
but why is this important some data
extracted from California and late 2017
shows that there was over 60 percent
overall detection rate of pesticides in
cannabis products this doesn't
necessarily mean it was a high failing
detection rate but the was of presence
of pesticides in the majority of the
products of the shelf I believe this is
being improved in recent months with the
increased level of testing California
has mandated but it is a reality that
has pesticides could be used in
cultivation or production of these
products
so the first challenge is a chemist is
identifying the right mrm these are the
transitions between the ionized
pesticide mass and its fragments that
are caused in the quadrupole of the
lc-ms mrm is multiple reaction
monitoring and because pesticides come
in a variety of different sizes and
weights there's a number of details that
can be looked at to optimize the method
taking acidic oil as an example we can
see that doing a quick literature search
for what's been done in other matrices
for this pesticide is not sufficient to
work in a cannabis environment cannabis
is a very complex material with a lot of
overlap with ions and suppression what
we were able to do is identify new mr
M's that allowed a much cleaner signal
from the pesticide when in a cannabis
sample this allows the quantitation to
be significantly more stronger and get a
better idea of if the pesticide is
present in the sample
another class of pesticides that have
gained some attention are the paraffins
and we see six of them here they share
similar masses and similar
characteristics in the lc/ms and what
was needed here was to perform a study
on using the right mrm
and what you'll see here is that that
study is fairly exhaustive and that it
does take a number of different
combinations of mass transfers to make
the right method for this chemistry in
this example the first transition
selection and the sixth transition
selection allowed us to get the
appropriate signal to noise from the
sample using this fragmented
fragmentation pattern using 2 3 4 & 5
proved ineffective in quantifying the
pesticide
you
and now we look at something slightly
different so depending on the type of
pesticide and the molecular makeup
sometimes it's necessary to look at
alternative ways of introducing that
pesticide into the lc-ms
an example here is chlorophenol and if
we use the traditional ESI source ESI is
electrospray ionisation in positive mode
we see that we can detect 1 ppm in the
top spectrum but we cannot detect 0.1
ppm this is a challenge because the
oregon state limit is one part per
million for the california is 0.1 so
this ESI source introductory mode would
not work for California
this can be addressed by using a
different type of ionization on the
lc-ms
we are able to use a PCI atmospheric
pressure chemical ionization this is a
second option for ionizing the pesticide
before it enters the lc-ms often thought
to be slightly softer in its nature but
what it does it allows a much more
robust signal to be addressed pertained
for the pesticide here we see the
signal-to-noise of over 50 being
sufficient to quantitate down to 0.1 ppm
necessary in California so we are now
confident that we can test all the
pesticides on one instrument using a
combination of the two sources
and this is also shown with compounds
such as Penta chloro nitrobenzene or PC
MB
you notice this molecule does not have
any protons or hydrogen atoms on it so
it's very challenging to ionize with
traditional ESI usually this is done on
the GCMs MS instruments but with a PCI
we can actually ionize this successfully
and quantitate this pesticide in the
California list very easily
and what's important for any
sighs method or any method in general is
the robustness we know that cannabis
samples are often quite challenging
they're sticky they can leave deposits
on the hardware as they're introduced to
the lc/ms so one of our studies was a
durability study here we can see 500
samples being run over the course of the
week and even without the internal
standard edition the reproducibility is
very strong increasing to 1.9 with the
use of the internal standard these are
very
satisfactory stability results and
provide a lot of confidence in labs
running a lot of samples so moving on
from the LC and LCMS chemistry GC
chemistry is also gaining a lot of
interest and momentum in the market and
why that is because you can break the
two classes of chemistry's down into
terpenes and residual solvents terpenes
are the aromatic molecules that all
plants flowers fruit has these give the
aroma the taste and and ultimately that
the market appeal in some of the
cannabis and hemp products terpenes only
contain carbon and hydrogen secondly
residual solvents are a very important
class of GC chemistry compounds these
are potential impurities left over from
the extraction process
some are toxic so understanding the
level and making sure it is low or
negative is important to ensuring the
quality of cannabis and hemp product
if
gives you an overview of the headspace
test or setup and it's a very elegant
and straightforward experiment we see on
the bottom left a vial you can place the
cannabis hemp flour etc sample in that
vial and that vial is then placed on the
autosampler and then the method is run
what happens is the vial is heated and
the volatile components of that sample
enter the gas above the vial this is
where the needle from the autosampler
collects the gas and transfers that over
to the GC or GCMs this is a very clean
way of introducing the terpenes as the
solids from the cannabis or hemp sample
remain in the vial
after the process a wire terpenes
important this is some data from a lab
in California SC labs and it shows that
for the Emerald cup which is a
significant
event where a lot of cannabis and hemp
samples are categorized and judged we
see that the mean difference for the
cannabinoids between the winners and the
overall is similar
quite interesting because some people
think a high potency or high cannabinoid
concentration means it means a valuable
product but in reality it was the
terpenes that can be shown to offer the
added value for the winners and here we
see deviation between the overall and
the winners being very clear in showing
the importance of having higher terpene
concentrations in the sample
this can also be seen in the literature
doing a quick search a number of papers
are available that speak to the
entourage effect of terpenes and
cannabinoids this is thought to be the
relationship of how the chemistry's work
together once ingested or in the body to
allow the medicinal effect of cannabis
terpenes are not only found in cannabis
and on the Left we see a number of the
common cannabis terpenes and also an
example of other plants or species that
we see the same terpene in and on the
right we're seeing a lot of value being
placed on identifying the type of
cannabis from its terpene profile users
can look to see the kind of effect or
terpene profile they want and it's a
very nice colorful way of identifying
the strains in the dispensary or
medicinal environment that a patient can
go to for that effect
and here we can see some of the
chemistry of both residual solvents and
terpenes first we're looking at a
residual solvent chromatogram this is
again the California list and as you can
see it's a fairly quick less than nine
minute run for differentiating and
quantitating all the residual solvents
needed to pass the California
regulations but what you do notice is
there are a couple Peaks that are very
close in retention time you can see the
pentane ethanol separation is very close
and you can see that the benzene 1-2
dichloroethane separation is very close
we can use GC mass spec to identify all
these compounds cleanly
if a GCF ID was used then the runtime
would have to be a little longer to
allow the separation but here we see the
value of adding the GCMs to the workflow
in the lab
and next we see a very busy yet exciting
chromatogram for the terpenes here we
can see 38 terpenes being quantitated in
about 8 minutes again this is a
reference to the California list but it
shows that there is great separation
between these different structures in a
very short time using GCMs
you
moving from the volatiles now we can
talk about heavy metal analysis in
cannabis and hemp
heavy metals are important and we know
that food farmer
testing of heavy metals is a daily
affair and with a lot of cannabis and
hemp products ending up in similar
product types understanding heavy metals
or
lack of hopefully is important what we
can see here is a snapshot of the states
that require heavy metal testing namely
California Colorado Massachusetts
Minnesota Washington etc and the
regulatory limits they've set for the
various types of cannabis product
we can see that there are particular
categories for both medical inhaled
topical in California so having
an icp-ms method for all of these is
important to ensure quality
and where the challenges can present
themselves is making sure you are able
to characterize all of the heavy metals
in the sample and we know a number of
samples can be very diverse hard candies
present a unique digestion challenge
high-fat oils topicals edibles also
present a challenge but we've been able
to work with laboratories to identify
the differences and produce methods that
can successfully digest each of these
samples and this is a good point to
speak to because making sure you have
complete digestion is essential for
getting a good result on the icp-ms
heavy metal assay in the top left we can
see that traditionally for a flour
sample it is placed into a acidic
environment and then it is then
microwave to be digested kokin Alma's
microwave is unique in that it can go to
higher pressures and temperatures since
most which allow a complete digestion
this is evident in the bottom left and
you see completely clear solutions for a
heavy metal digest you want to see a
clear acidic solution at the end any
particulate or color in the solution
means that was not a successful
digestion the instrument in the middle
is the microwave digester and then the
instrument on the right is the icp-ms
fairly well-known method for cannabis
and hemp and sample throughput can be as
quick the 60 to 90 seconds
and lastly chemistry that we didn't
speak about at the beginning but is
gaining traction
due to its convenience in the
cultivation and manufacturing
environment is FTIR chemistry
FTIR commonly used the nutraceutical
food raw material Industries is being
adopted by PerkinElmer to be used in
cannabis and hemp firstly we're going to
look at using near-infrared
for understanding the potency of the
cannabis sample here we can see the
spectrum to near-infrared instrument on
the right and a small petri dish with
cannabis flower in it this is a
non-destructive test so that flower can
then be used after the test but what we
see here is the flower being placed into
a circular spinning cup which spins to
make sure a representative spectrum of
that flower sample is taken for
near-infrared analysis and once this is
done
we're able to get
the spectrum of the cannabinoid in that
particular sample and here we can see a
number of samples overlaid and some
subtle differences in the chemistry
applying some mathematics and modeling
that come included with the method we're
able actually to see the differences
between THC components and CBD
components of the flower
this allows us to put together a
reference model so it can be used on the
laboratory bench or the cultivation
bench in a cultivation environment and
what this workflow looks like is here we
see a straight forward grind of the
sample it placed on the near-infrared
and initially a model is made and that
model comes from representative samples
with supporting data for the cannabinoid
but once the model is made and it has
been you can then run an unknown on that
near-infrared and expect the potency
concentration to be stated or shown very
quickly so we now have a non-destructive
test that takes about a minute to run in
the lab or the cultivation environment
this can be expanded upon in some of the
literature out there that will be
available at the end of this talk it's
not on the website
and then a second application which is
becoming very
popular in the extraction community is
monitoring the decarboxylation reaction
of THC a to THC
we know that THC a is not utilized in
the body as effectively as THC so a lot
of edible topical extraction producers
want to convert that THC a to THC this
is conditionally done by just heating
the sample and stirring it until the co2
bubbles dissipate this is thought to be
very inconsistent and offer poor quality
control because overextending the
heating will also drive off some of the
terpenes that are volatile we address
this by using STI our and what you're
looking at here is the stage of the
sample of oil that's taken from a larger
reaction batch this can be taken every
10 15 minutes very quickly and easily
but it can then provide insight into how
quickly that decarboxylation reaction is
happening and we can see on the left the
O H peak and the c o h peaks of the FTIR
spectrum dissipating as the reaction
continues
provides a lot of information about
what's happening in that reaction
process and allows the user to model
so that they have an idea exactly when
they achieve the right THC concentration
and here we can see data from
experimental and also from the model
that showed excellent correlation the
moving forward is now a fairly elegant
quick instrument option for looking at
the decarboxylation of THC a 2 THC
and lastly wrapping up
like to speak to the application
readiness of her pinellas team for
cannabis and hemp what's included with
every instrument in a cannabis and hemp
application is an SOP dedicated to that
particular sample and in this case we're
looking at the references for the
pesticide the potency a heavy metal and
the residual solvent SOP that come with
the instrument these are designed to
offer a step-by-step method and workflow
that a lab can implement to be
successful and minimize any or reduce
the amount of development that might be
needed for that sample
these are available for all the
instruments for all the cannabis markets
we support
and extending the knowledge please feel
free to reference the application
materials available online or contact me
at the end of this webinar and I'd be
happy to share but there are a number of
publications co-authored by cannabis
laboratories and collaborators and
PerkinElmer that demonstrate some of the
exciting chemistry that can be done
today in this environment we continue to
grow this portfolio so I'm excited to
provide updates moving forward
and in summary I just like to conclude
that PerkinElmer is excited to be
involved in this industry and although
that the chemistry is challenging we
have addressed a lot of the near-term
needs of the laboratory to make the
testing go as smooth as possible and
provide the support and that support
comes in a variety of options whether it
be hardware software application support
we have an extended team as excited to
work with you as this industry grows and
lastly as mentioned we provide the
standard operating procedure with all
the instruments talked about today to
make your life as straightforward and
easy as possible and also get you to
testing cannabis and hemp samples as
quickly as possible with the confidence
that you need to be successful
and with that I'd like to say thank you
for your attention I look forward to any
questions and if you have any comments
or questions please feel free to reach
out to my email below thank you for your
time thank you dr. Asheville for your
presentation quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. asked a will answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is can you use the PerkinElmer
headspace autosampler on a non
PerkinElmer GC that's a great question
and the short answer is yes we recognize
that a number of laboratories already
have GC of g CMS's in their facility but
adding the terpene and residual solvent
method does require headspace
autosampler so we do have options to
configure the PerkinElmer headspace to a
non PerkinElmer GC the next one is can
you run all the pesticides on one lc/ms
that is a great question and I could
spend a lot longer speaking to that but
yes the answer is we can and that is
possible because of the dual source
nature of the LCMS so the compounds
traditionally run on GCM SMS can be run
using a PCI ionisation on our LCMS
countries like Canada have a fairly long
pesticide list of 95 but those have been
successfully run on the one instrument
so as the regulatory world changes we
continually update but know we can run
all the pesticides on one instrument
next one is can you send the standard
operating procedure
we can but it is a piece of the overall
solution from PerkinElmer cannabis team
so it does come with the purchase of one
of the instruments it's not a public
document if you have questions about one
of the SOPs in particular I'd be happy
to speak to some of the detail but they
do come with the instrument upon
installation what about cannabis food
and beverage samples
yes this is exciting topic we're seeing
a huge amount of activity coming from
the more traditional food nutraceutical
environments because they are being
approached or they are interested in
working with cannabis or hemp CBD a lot
of them already do have some expertise
with the food sample but there is some
challenge when introducing the cannabis
component so we are excited to do
research method development and work in
the regulatory spaces where cannabis
food products and beverages are
available
hey thanks looks like we have time for
one more question can you look at CBD
terpene profiles
yes so the CPB topic because of the
growth in the hemp market in the u.s.
recently has been extensive and CBD is
one of the many cannabinoids present in
the plant so as I mentioned briefly at
the beginning HPLC can be used to
characterize that concentration where we
are seeing a huge amount of research is
looking at the stability of CBD a lot of
CBD products are in beverages topicals
and they need to be shelf stable and
cannabinoids don't like to be in
hydrophilic environments so we're
actually looking at some interesting
science about stability of CBD where
other characterization techniques are
required and terpenes to the same extent
very much so I spoke to the method being
used traditionally GCMs with the
headspace we have got clients looking at
over 150 terpenes in their product not
all of them are at a large concentration
but there are a number that are very low
so looking at those those with a GCMs
allows the sensitivity so we are excited
to keep growing our application breath
the terpene profiling chemistry's one we
have considerable interest and resources
focused on right now I would like to
once again thank dr. astril for his
presentation Dan any final comments uh
only to help where I can and people like
to reach out to me on my email I'll be
happy to reply as soon as possible
but no thank you for the opportunity
today thanks again I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor PerkinElmer for underwriting
today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through June 2019 lab routes
will alert you via email and it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye